depuis cinq ans il fait la fierté de son
directeur se méthaniseur permet de
transformer le lisier et le fumier des
animaux de la ferme de la tramblais en
biogaz
il devient lui-même de l'électricité
puis du chauffage avec d'autres mesures
elle a permis à la ferme d'obtenir le
certificat iso 14001 une norme pour
appuyer son engagement en faveur de
l'environnement
ce qui nous oblige donc à avoir une
méthodologie à gérer des non conformités
à communiquer auprès du personnel pour
dire voilà pourquoi on fait ça au
personnel nous ne répondrons mais il
nous manque que ceux-ci ceci pour
améliorer notre sens de protéger
l'environnement dans une telle démarche
interactive reçu en 2006 son certificat
a été renouvelé comme elle une dizaine
d'autres fermes yvelinoise ont obtenu
leur renouvellement des exploitants qui
favorise la crau écologie regroupés au
sein de l'association terre des yvelines
notre groupe a pris conscience de ce
besoin de communiquer ce besoin de
certifier nos performances des
indicateurs concrets validée par un
bureau extérieur qui vient dire voilà
ces années plus tard la respecte la
réglementation ont mis en place des
actions
à vocation environnementale et vont dans
le bon sens je produis du blé du colza
je ne travaille plus le seul d'autres je
laboure plus pour favoriser la vie
finalement dans le sol et pau
schématiser grosso modo bajeux
préserve les vers de terre qui est
finalement enrichissent le sol christian
n'utilise plus de produits chimiques et
son huile serre dans le btp pour
produire de l'électricité et de la
chaleur
terre des yvelines espèrent toucher de
nouveaux exploitants pour favoriser une
agriculture durable dans le département